another odd moment from Donald Trump's
bizarre and bloviating press conference
last week was when Donald Trump said hey
that the public has no interest in
seeing my tax returns only media cares
about that that could not be further
from the truth according to a new ABC
News poll 74% of Americans want to see
Trump's tax returns this is even more
than the number that wanted to see them
before the election Trump's anticipated
reaction at 3:30 a.m. on Twitter I don't
know probably something like 74 percent
of Americans are buying into fake news
they're dumb enough to pay taxes unlike
me that makes me smart sad low-energy I
haven't actually seen that tweet pat but
I'm sure Trump will write it off as no
big deal as he does with most things
also from the same poll before he even
takes office 43% of Americans already
believe Trump is not abiding by federal
ethics laws I'm glad Trump is really
draining the swamp and fighting
corruption and exhibiting full
transparency by showing us what
potential conflicts of interest oh wait
a second no he's not he's not doing that
at all and the funny thing is he's
forgetting the entire thing he repeated
countless times I can't release the tax
returns because I'm being audited I'll
received release them as soon as the
audit is done of course not that that
matters the IRS has already said an
audit doesn't prevent you from releasing
tax returns but Trump will never release
the tax returns the only option as I've
mentioned is hacking them go back to
2011 in 2011 Trump said we'll look at
that maybe I'm going to do the tax
returns when Obama does his birth
certificate I'd love to give you my tax
returns of course we got the birth
certificate still no taxes 2014 Trump
saying if I decide to run for office if
I'll produce my tax returns absolutely
and I would love to do that no tax
returns Trump in 2015 I would certainly
show my tax returns if necessary well I
guess that he doesn't find it to be
necessary and I won't even give you the
list of 2016 quotes because the show is
only an hour long
reporters rather than standing aside
while Trump bashes CNN in public they
should unite and
just ask Trump about the tax returns at
every opportunity every press conference
Rachel the question should be when will
you release your tax returns we want to
see what's in there we need to figure
out what conflicts of interest there are
and there's this unwritten rule that
sort of exists among reporters which is
if another reporter is sort of not
allowed to ask a question who ever gets
called on necks can ask the question
that the ignored reporter was going to
ask and I think that here this needs to
be sort of applied as a group 74% of
Americans want those tax returns every
reporter should just ask for them every
time they get a chance to ask a question
oh they totally should but then there's
people like Breitbart who will just
release an article and say oh no it's
totally ok and Elizabeth Elizabeth
Warren's potential bill is just an
attack on Trump and when John Kerry's
wife only released the first two summary
pages and no one noticed there so yeah
so those journalists will support him
they won't ask the best move for me from
the entire press conference was
immediately after calling CNN fake news
he goes
Breitbart what question would you like
to ask us yeah and that was the first
press conference in a long time so you
could see that if they keep going after
him on these tax returns he could just
shut down altogether yeah and not have
any more of them oh yeah and III know
that that is something he said he's not
gonna be like Hillary who didn't do a
press conferences for a very long time
Trump's going to do press conferences I
hope he sticks to that but I am not
convinced that if it starts getting
adversarial the press conferences will
continue thanks for watching this video
before you watch the next one remember
we're raising money to expand the David
Pakman show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated